meet rob he runs an online shopping
portal the portal started with a modest
number of users but has recently been
seeing a surge in the number of visitors
on black friday and other holidays the
portal saw so many visitors that the
servers were unable to handle the
traffic and crashed
is there a way to improve performance
without having to invest in a new server
wondered rob
a way to upscale or downscale capacity
depending on the number of users
visiting the website at any given point
well there is amazon web services one of
the leaders in the cloud computing
market
before we see how aws can solve rob's
problem let's have a look at how aws
reach the position it is at now
aws was first introduced in 2002 as a
means to provide tools and services to
developers to incorporate features of
amazon.com to their website
in 2006 its first cloud services
offering was introduced
in 2016 aws surpassed its 10 billion
revenue target
and now aws offers more than 100 cloud
services that span a wide range of
domains thanks to this the aws cloud
service platform is now used by more
than 45 of the global market
now let's talk about what is aws
aws or amazon web service is a secure
cloud computing platform that provides
computing power database networking
content storage and much more
the platform also works with a
pay-as-you-go pricing model which means
you only pay for how much of the service
is offered by aws you use
some of the other advantages of aws are
security aws provides a secure and
durable platform that offers end-to-end
privacy and security
experience you can benefit from the
infrastructure management practices born
from amazon's years of experience
flexible it allows users to select the
os language database and other services
easy to use users can host applications
quickly and securely
scalable depending on user requirements
applications can be scaled up or down
aws provides a wide range of services
across various domains
what if rob wanted to create an
application for his online portal aws
provides compute services that can
support the app development process from
start to finish
from developing deploying running to
scaling the application up or down based
on the requirements
the popular services include ec2 aws
lambda amazon light cell and elastic
bean stock for storing website data rob
could use aws storage services that
would enable him to store access govern
and analyze data to ensure that costs
are reduced agility is improved and
innovation accelerated
popular services within this domain
include amazon s3 ebs s3 glacier and
elastic file storage
rob can also store the user data in a
database with aw services which he can
then optimize and manage
popular services in this domain include
amazon rds dynamodb and redshift
if rob's businesses took off and he
wanted to separate his cloud
infrastructure or scale up his work
requests and much more he would be able
to do so with the networking services
provided by aws
some of the popular networking services
include amazon vpc amazon route 53 and
elastic load balancing
other domains that aws provide services
in are analytics blockchain containers
machine learning internet of things and
so on
and there you go
that's aws for you in a nutshell now
before we're done let's have a look at a
quiz
which of these services are incorrectly
matched one
two
three
four
we'll be pinning the question in the
comment section comment below with your
answer and stand a chance to win an
amazon voucher
several companies around the world have
found great success with aws companies
like netflix twitch linkedin facebook
and bbc have taken advantage of the
services offered by aws to improve their
business efficiency
and thanks to their widespread usage aws
professionals are in high demand they're
highly paid and earn up to more than 127
000 per annum once you're aws certified
you could be one of them too
take your first step towards getting
certified by clicking on the top right
corner
if you enjoyed this video a thumbs up
would be really appreciated
don't forget to subscribe to the simply
learn channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update on the latest
trending technologies
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simplylearn
[Music]
you